welcome back to CBS mornings here at 7
30 where we are learning new details in
the CBS News investigation about a
federal lawsuit accusing Twitter of
complicity in a brutal campaign of
repression by Saudi Arabia to silence
its critics a Saudi Aid worker who used
an anonymous Twitter account to mock
Saudi Arabia was arrested in Riyadh back
in 2018 and allegedly tortured now his
American sister is speaking out in an
exclusive interview with our chief
investigative correspondent Jim axelrado
joins us now Jim good morning Good
morning Tony when Elon Musk took over
Twitter last fall he did so with
financial backing from Saudi Arabia the
deal reaffirmed a close commercial
relationship established years earlier
between the social media company and the
kingdom a bond a woman named arij
al-sadan says led to the arrest and
torture of her younger brother
I want proof of life I want to be able
to see my brother and speak to him and
make sure that he is okay
an American citizen and her brother
Abdul Rahman a Saudi national grew up
splitting time between the U.S and Saudi
Arabia when was the last time he spoke
to your brother more than five years ago
that's because her brother sits in a
Saudi prison cell not allowed to
communicate with his family his friends
miss him
um I miss him dearly after finishing
College in California in 2013 Abdul
Rahman returned to Riyadh and a job as a
humanitarian Aid worker you have a good
sense of humor oh yeah yeah but it was
that sense of humor that got him in
trouble his Twitter account mocking
Saudi officials and religious figures
grew to a hundred sixty thousand
followers is Twitter important inside
Saudi Arabia there is no freedom of
speech so Twitter became more like the
forum for people to express themselves
mostly anonymously in its privacy policy
Twitter assured users it does not
disclose private personal information
except in limited circumstances but in a
new lawsuit a rige accuses Twitter of
improperly divulging Abdul rahman's
identity to the Saudis and becoming a
tool of transnational repression how did
you discover your brother was missing he
used to call my mom every single day she
was the first to notice the calls were
not going through the messages were not
going through and my mom was freaking
out co-workers eventually told the
family Saudi officials arrested Abdul
Rahman at his office and they later
learned he was being held and tortured
they rocker's hand smashed his fingers
saying this is the hand you tweet with
after three years he was brought to a
secret hearing Abdul Rahman al-sidan was
charged with violating Saudi
anti-terrorism laws he was prosecuted
under counter-terrorism laws yes for
tweeting yes they want people to be
afraid to speak out to say look if you
dare to criticize us this is what we're
going to charge you with in 2021 he was
sentenced to 20 years in prison followed
by a 20-year travel ban none of this
would have happened but for Twitter's
corruption that's big word it is but
Twitter lit diffuse attorney Jim Walden
represents a Regal sadan in her civil
suit and points to a criminal case in
California for what they claim is
Twitter's complicity in disclosing Abdul
rahman's identity for the first time
Federal authorities are accusing Saudi
Arabia of a spying in the U.S last year
a former Twitter manager was convicted
of acting as is a foreign agent for KSA
or the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia one of
two employees caught accepting bribes to
pass along confidential user data then
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia weaponized
that information evidence at trial
suggested Abdul rahman's personal
information was linked to the Saudis
three years before his arrest Twitter
itself was never charged and has set a
cut off access to the Bad actors if
there hadn't been any leak from inside
Twitter would abdulrahman's identity
still be unknown to the KSA regime he
would still be anonymous he would still
be free Walden alleges a conspiracy
forged by the growing Financial ties
between the tech company and the kingdom
which first invested in Twitter in 2011.
given the closeness of the relationship
given the amount of money that the
Saudis were giving Twitter and it's
impossible to conclude that Twitter had
no idea this was happening Twitter
declined our requests for comment and
offering only this earthy Emoji as an
automated response when Elon Musk bought
the company last year a Saudi fund
maintained its investment they now hold
the second largest stake in Twitter
behind musk what I'm worried about is
that as a condition of their deal with
musk to stay as an owner that they got
special access Connecticut Senator Chris
Murphy has asked the Biden
Administration to review whether the
musk deal jeopardized National Security
by giving the Saudi government access to
more private user data including for U.S
citizens he says the administration
refused I don't know why the
administration didn't look into this but
for a long time we've looked the other
way Saudi Arabia's outrageous behavior
both domestically and in the region
because we wanted their oil we need to
speak up for him
told her she can no longer stay quiet
about her brother's case despite
receiving threats she says are the work
of Saudi leadership one of them says I'm
gonna rape you and I'm gonna murder you
I mean this is horrendous this is crazy
and of course when you remember what
happened to journalist Jamal khashoggi
you know how serious that is these
people are serious about their threats
Saudi Arabia is also named as a
defendant in arija's lawsuit and
declined to comment in correspondence
with human rights investigators at the
United Nations the kingdom maintained
Abdul Rahman violated anti-terrorism
laws and denied his family's claims of
torture the U.N investigators didn't buy
it in a September opinion they
determined Abdul rahman's arrest and
detention were quote arbitrary and
lacked a legal basis and said no trial
should have taken place wow so what's
next now for the lawsuit well uh the
suit has been filed Twitter's been
served in fact the deadline for Twitter
to respond is today they've asked for an
extension Saudi Arabia has not been
served yet we will of course keep you
updated very brave I think of the sister
to speak out on her brother's behalf
knowing how you can be treated in Saudi
Arabia and it raises the question back
to the live golf tournament why why
these kind of stories matter because
many people are saying how could we do
business with a government that behaves
that way based on the story that you
just told and I hear there are many
stories like that yeah and that's
obviously that what is spiking a lot of
intense emotion about the arrangement
yesterday that was announced between Liv
and the PGA I will say that there's
several hurdles in that particular story
among them a doj investigation into
whether it violates any sort of
Anti-Trust laws to have that monolithic
golf entity also makes you realize both
sides must have had something that was
more preferable emerging than it was
going to court the PGA Tour certainly
didn't want to get into a battle a legal
battle in terms of how much you have to
pay and the Saudis probably didn't want
to enter in any kind of Discovery yeah
Jim this is an eye-opening investigation
yeah yeah thank you so much